[Applaudissements]
ça donne retrouver une ligne fine et en
sept jours seulement moi en une semaine
j'ai perdu trois kilos perdus mais à
moitié avec la cure j'ai perdu 15 kilos
ben moi j'ai perdu 200 balles non plus
ça m'a filé des boutons qu'une fille
tout le monde se fout de ma gueule à
l'aquagym
[Musique]
ce
sa chasse
nous sommes aujourd'hui qu'il avait rien
n'y fait
nous recevons daniele christine de récup
française mais qui vivent à monaco et
qu'elle fasse un maquillage mais en
beauté plus naturel et c'est à paris que
nous retrouvons à serra pour sa journée
shopping année va pas de chrono
christina est prête à suivre votre
shopping depuis son bureau
alors déjà un canton rend dans une
boutique on dit bonjour
welcome et 2 il est 18 heures on est
fermée merci bonne journée
m tu veux dire au revoir kaunas
décidément de françoise vous récupérez
la lèpre
oui couscous c'est sa mère la [ __ ]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]